how did you all find each other and to
tell the story we lived in the same town
yeah we can reach tell our own version
we can each tell her a version of it cuz
there's really a sequence in how we came
came together because Jeffrey and I
first the quilt in Washington at the
inaugural display and we're so you know
well you you see it here but we were so
taken by the enormity of it and the
deeply personal nature of it and we were
with our good friend Peter Adair a
filmmaker who happens to be happened to
be my mentor and Peter looked at us and
said someone needs to make a film about
this and we went back to San Francisco
and ran with that and met with with the
name's project and found out that Cindy
Ruskin was working on a book about the
quilt and we met with Cindy and decided
to partner in researching stories and we
were under way with that process and
then we got a call from bill and I was
in at Los Angeles and I was laying down
four panels of the quilt at the point
the villian the first time that the AIDS
quilt appeared in Southern California
was the size of a basketball court and I
was in the middle of making a movie and
I wasn't getting along with my director
who you Hudson
who direct the chair it's a fire and I
remember saying to myself I better get
along with him because he could ban me
from the set and so I decided to invite
him to the laying down of the panels and
I was laying down my boyfriend's four of
them and my friends were floating above
me and it was a very very hard time and
I lay down in a fetal position on the
quilt and just started to cry when I saw
you Hudson come down from the eaves and
saying to me put your grief and anger
into it this film make it a movie about
the quilt but it was like a Liberty Bell
fell on my head and the first thing I
did was called Bill who I knew from dear
America and I mentioned it and he said
well we're doing it
and actually Durham Erica is a segue let
me do it quickly I'd done a film for HBO
called dear America which won its first
IMI's and it was premiered to can and
the Grand Palais and then it was a big
deal for HBO that was before HBO was HBO
right I mean it was it was the start
right right it was there was the polka
shows and stuff so they were just trying
they could actually michael Fuchs who
used to run and said I can't afford to
do a movie I can't afford to do a TV
show but I can afford to do a [ __ ]
dock and that was not this well that was
some earlier ones but anyhow I did dear
America big hit and michael Fuchs who
ran the place said bill I'll let you do
any movie you want to do which you'd
never hear that at least I never heard
it and I said okay well great and I was
on the road with dear America and Cathy
called my wife who had seen the quilt at
Moscone Center and she said bill I've
seen your next movie I said well I'll
decide that
she said well come see it and when you
come home you just got to come see this
because this is important and I did and
they blew me away and so I called
Michael I said Michael I've got my next
movie it's on the AIDS quilt and he said
oh we can't do that that's you know AIDS
yuck and he didn't mean I mean Michael
actually was not a homophobe at all but
he was a commercial you know network guy
and he just said I was gonna watch a
movie about a quilt guys dying and I
said okay well you know why don't you
see it it's coming to New York go see it
and to give him credit he went it was
there for and I was there this is a big
deal and he looked around he goes okay
yeah I got it and he was like totally
blow blowing it all and I was like oh
god and then he looked down and this is
this is actually a true story he looked
down and he was standing on a panel
for michael Fuchs same name not
different guy obviously and the just you
know it struck him that there before the
grace of God goes he and he said okay
I'll do it but you're gonna get half as
much money because no one's gonna watch
this thing and then we I talked to
cleave you had talked to cleave and
Michael and we said let's do this
together and there it goes